[Musique]
c'est à l'atelier des lots institut de
beauté situé à sainte clotilde que la
chambre des métiers organisé une
conférence de presse pour présenter un
point d'étape sur le dispositif passe
bien être à laquelle a été conviée le
département 16 millions d'euros ont été
mobilisés par la collectivité pour la
mise en place de ce dispositif qui
s'inscrit dans le cadre du plan de
relance économiques et sociales liées à
la crise sanitaire actuelle
c'est un dispositif qui vient en soutien
donc de deniers publics au département
les bénéficiaires les foyers
bénéficiaires du rsa et les personnes de
plus de 60 ans disposant d'une petite
retraite
mais ça vient aussi par la même occasion
en soutien de l'activité économique
puisque puisque ses potentiels clients
vont pouvoir consommer des prestations
chez les présidents de chaque foyer
bénéficiaire reçoit
une page de 10 coupons le tout valant
150 euros et chaque coupon valant 15 ans
alors ils peuvent l'utiliser chez un ou
plusieurs prestataires
ils ne sont pas attachés un seul
prestataire il est choisi ce à partir
d'une plateforme numérique et ensuite
vous consommez les soins
ce dispositif permet ainsi aux publics
fragiles isolées ou en souffrance de
bénéficier de prestations de bien-être
de pratiquer des activités sportives de
loisirs au culturel
je veux dire que c'est une très bonne
chose ça permettrait plutôt de plus
modernisé la femme pop la femme soit
indépendante et à sa voix qu'il ya des
femmes qui ont des foyers qui
privilégient leur foyer avant tout leur
la facture tout ça à gérer les enfants
et tours donc elles ont tendance à se
négliger un peu et avec se passe ça va
les bouffer un petit peu plus pour
pouvoir prendre soin d'elle mise en
place il ya trois mois et pour une durée
de 12 mois ce dispositif vient en
soutien aux métiers de l'artisanat afin
de compenser la perte importante de
chiffre d'affaires de ces petites
entreprises ça nous ramène ça nous
apporte en fait de nouvelles clientes
des clients qui vont peut-être venir
pour certains voient là et en même temps
un peu de bouche à oreille aussi voilà
par exemple pour le mois de janvier
comparé à l'année dernière
en janvier généralement c'est un mois qu
est assez car ça nous a ramené le double
en fait au niveau des clips de la
clientèle donc c'est comme si on avait
fait 1 mois de décembre et en janvier
pour bénéficier de cette aide rendez
vous sur passe bien n'être point
département 9 7 4 points fr ou par
téléphone au 02 62 67 13 47 mais
également par courrier en téléchargeant
le formulaire sur département 9 7 4
points est faire slash passe bien être
[Musique]